[Musica]
io mi occupo di coltura mi occupo di
comunicazione museale e molto spesso
sono a contatto con i giovani delle
scuole dalle elementari fino alle
superiori per progetti che li
coinvolgono nella costruzione di guide
turistiche di percorsi personalizzati
quindi trascorrendo molto tempo
all'interno di musei e devo dire che non
sempre la loro prima impressione è molto
positiva anzi oserei dire che il
pacchetto pensano subito che si
annoieranno in realtà non sono solamente
i giovani adolescenti a considerare la
cultura noiosa
anzi secondo una ricerca presentata già
nel 2011 a lubecca
un evento che a lucca si occupa di beni
culturali le parole che più spesso
venivano associate ad una visita al
museo
secondo i giovani fino ai 35 anni
quindi in realtà neppure più tanto
giovani erano in realtà noi a vedere una
visita al museo come un obbligo e
considerare l'istituzione museale come
un'istituzione vecchia e questo è un
problema
questo è un problema soprattutto se si
pensa che fra le mission del museo vi è
la comunicazione del passato alle
generazioni future
ma se le generazioni future se i giovani
di oggi che saranno gli adulti di domani
consigliamo di musei noiosi entreranno
veramente nei musei
per questo motivo la missione del museo
del 2020 è quella di riuscire a
modificare il proprio linguaggio
comunicativo adottandolo a quello dei
più giovani che può significare inserire
lo smartphone durante una visita guidata
attraverso magari la lettura di quel
record
oppure integrare delle ricostruzioni 3d
all'interno del percorso museale più
semplicemente può significare consentire
la condivisione sui social media delle
opere d'arte più importanti
tutto ciò insomma che può favorire il
fatto che il museo diventi parte della
quotidianità dei giovani che riescono a
comprenderlo come un qualcosa che
è separato dal loro vissuto ma che fa
parte di ciò che fanno quotidianamente
in tal senso lo scorso anno uno degli
esempi più potenti prevede da un museo
che qua dentro tutti conoscerete forse
qualcuno non l'ha visto ma tutti
sappiamo dove si trova il louvre e tutti
magari pensiamo banalmente che lui non
abbia bisogno di comunicare il proprio
marchio il louvre esiste è
un'istituzione per famosissima tutti
quelli che vanno a parigi forse hanno
visto il luca almeno una volta
in realtà secondo il mediatore culturale
del museo il louvre non è cool
non è attrattivo per i giovani ed è per
questo che lo scorso anno ha aperto le
proprie porte di notte a beyoncé una
cantante pop famosa nella musica
internazionale tanto quanto il lucro nei
musei e ha consentito a lei di girare un
proprio video proprio in quelle sale in
questa maniera le le opere d'arte che
normalmente sarebbero visitabili
solamente dentro il museo sono state
improvvisamente catapultati negli
smartphone nelle televisioni di milioni
di giovani in questa maniera forse
vedere napoleone bonaparte che si
autoproclama imperatore non diventa più
così noioso o vecchio per un adolescente
questo non è un'operazione spot state
bene attenti perché il look rosa
costruendo adesso degli itinerari che
ricalcano proprio le opere d'arte
davanti alle quali ha ballato bene o
insieme questo in qualche maniera
rientra all'interno di due ampi discorsi
e le tecniche che ormai si stanno
applicando della comunicazione museale e
che sono lo storytelling e la
gamification sono due termini inglesi lo
storytelling vuol dire banalmente
narrare il louvre l'ha fatto da
raccontando l'itinerario di beyoncé se
lo vogliamo che marco si di fatto si
tratta di costruire un percorso di
costruire delle storie che raccontano un
territorio che raccontano una collezione
gamification invece un termine diverso
in realtà vuol dire in italiano g
ficcare perché suona malissimo sarebbe
applicare dinamiche di gioco in contesti
in cui il gioco è normalmente non si
applica può voler dire che in un
videogame dio o la possibilità di
aumentare la mia esperienza
se entro in un museo e vedo determinati
i quadri può significare che aumento il
mio punteggio di gioco se visito più
punti di interesse
questo avviene anche in italia nel 2017
museo archeologico di napoli ha
realizzato father and son paio di giorni
fa è uscito anche per android
l'applicazione wunder bob della comune
di bologna dedicato ai musei civici
medievale al museo di palazzo poggi e
anche in italia staccati nati in sicilia
sta accadendo qualcosa di simile si
chiama sicily stories ed è
un'applicazione geolocalizzata quindi al
contrario di quello che abbiamo visto
prima non si tratta di qualcosa che si
può vedere anche da casa ma devo essere
in sicilia the west nel territorio per
poterlo utilizzare un'applicazione che
racconta il territorio scaricata da
circa tremila persone nei soli primi
cinque mesi di rilascio su store e che
racconta il territorio direttamente
attraverso le avventure di personaggi
che si spostano nei diversi luoghi della
regione raccontando i diversi periodi
storici della sicilia e quindi per
scoprire le avventure del garibaldino
ulisse non ci dovremmo fermare a marsala
quando sbarcò insieme ai mille ma
dovremo accompagnarlo a palermo nella
battaglia del ponte dell'ammiraglio e
arrivare insieme a catania e in ogni
punto di interesse in ogni luogo
l'utente avrà modo di potersi mettere
alla prova con dei giochi di abilità con
di giochi in realtà aumentata o dei
giochi che banalmente sono dei quiz che
gli consentono di capire se
effettivamente ciò che ha letto nelle
guide è stato memorizzato
per ogni punto di interesse
correttamente completato potrà poi
vincere dei premi spendibili anche sul
territorio però c'è un detto un detto
che dice che se ascolto dimentico se
vedo ricordo
e faccio capisco e per questo motivo noi
di hi stories
abbiamo voluto mettere sicily stories
nelle mani dei ragazzi delle scuole
quelli che vedete qua al castello ursino
di catania sono fra le prime classi che
hanno lavorato al sicily stories come
creatori di contenuti
abbiamo dato ai ragazzi delle scuole
superiori la possibilità di scrivere le
storie dei personaggi scrivere i giochi
dei punti di interesse e di fatto
renderli protagonisti non soltanto della
fruizione del territorio ma anche della
sua valorizzazione e della sua tutela
perché se il passato deve arrivare alle
generazioni future c'è bisogno che quel
passato venga protetto oggi e venga
conservato oggi non domani
le altre cose proprio questi ragazzi
notari talmente tanto bravi che questo
l'itinerario dedicato ai castelli
federiciani quindi castelli della canna
di catania ha realizzati da federico ii
di svevia venisse poi presentato a
matera 2019 durante un evento dedicato
alle scuole a carattere nazionale
questi sono esempi che ci fanno
immaginare quindi che è il digitale e la
cultura soprattutto la cultura
umanistica siano ormai come dire vadano
d'accordo che non ci siano più problemi
che finalmente i musei siano pieni di
ricostruzioni 3d di quel record di tutto
ma in realtà non è così e non è così
perché molto spesso in passato gli
esempi di digital esempi legati
all'utilizzo della tecnologia in ambito
culturale non sono stati dei più felici
quest'acqua una schermata del pokémon go
prima abbiamo visto il logo ora vediamo
cosa era due anni fa tantissimi appunto
giocavano cercando questi mostriciattoli
in un certo momento della vita di questa
applicazione era possibile rintracciarli
anche dentro i musei pokémon go si
trovavano dentro i musei si trovavano
dei bar si trovavano all'interno delle
proprie abitazioni
ma quante persone effettivamente
senza sbattere la testa ovviamente l'uno
contro l'altro si rendevano conto che un
pokémon era dentro un museo e si
accorgevano di quello che c'era dentro
il museo le realtà aumentata uno
strumento molto potente ma in questo
caso uno strumento vuoto perché si ok mi
fa vedere qualcosa che non c'è nella
realtà attraverso il mio dispositivo ma
è sconnesso rispetto a quella che è la
realtà non mi da un contenuto di qualità
è un contenuto che deve essere
necessario quando si parla di
comunicazione culturale perché soltanto
se la cultura e la tecnologia diventa
uno strumento messo al servizio della
cultura che fornisce dei contenuti che
fornisce degli elementi aggiuntivi nella
rappresentazione del museo nella visita
guidata se fornisce uno spunto allora
consente ai più giovani uno snack di
smettere di considerare il museo comune
in realtà stantia ma considerarlo
finalmente quello che vale a dire un
luogo coinvolgente e stimolante
[Applauso]
[Musica]